[Musique] étrangère
car on voit tellement de gens venir ici pour
le petit-déjeuner pendant ces 13 années où
je dirige cette organisation à but non lucratif
sans abri. La vie nous n'avons jamais eu autant de
monde nous vivons dans un pays très riche
mais la société est devenue beaucoup plus cool
maintenant et les gens ont besoin d'aide
[Musique]
merci,
la première vague d'inflation concernait uniquement
les prix de l'énergie et certains prix d'importation, mais
maintenant cela s'est propagé à l'ensemble de l'
économie, nous avons donc de larges couches de
prix qui augmentent les
personnes étrangères [Musique] [Musique] vivant  aux véritables marges de
la société, cela a maintenant changé, même
les enfants des familles, les personnes âgées, les
personnes en congé de maladie, ont tous du
mal à survivre
[Musique]